dating can be difficult especially when
you meet all different types of people
come on one more drink meet the Taurus
the Taurus says she's bisexual well
after three drinks she is she won't
hesitate to make out for the sake of
that good old college experimentation
but even after a month of nights spent
together anything below the fanny pack
and it's suddenly okay we keep picking
out or don't do salsa juanio it becomes
abundantly clear that she's only a
tourist here and not a permanent
resident you're gonna order a rum and
coke
meet the psychic she's someone who
thinks he knows you better than you know
yourself he'll try to predict your
sexuality before you do they'll tell you
that he was once bisexual too and we all
go through that phase and eventually
he'll be able to predict the future I
see you leaving me wait what the Jack
Tripper believes that Three's Company is
a motto to live by he thinks that your
sexuality means that you're always down
for a threesome and ready to jump in the
sack with any girl as long as he's there
yeah
chemistry here palpable
going out will always result in him
asking if we can take home that girl or
that girl
or that girl the detective is always on
the job and always suspicious of you
you'll find you're constantly
interrogating you about your sexuality
what percent straight are you she'll ask
for so what do you call yourself or if
you had to choose between men and women
who would you choose have I told you the
one about having a moon landing
there's the conspiracy theorist she has
clearly been burned before and she's
convinced that you'll leave her for a
man which to her is more devastating
than leaving her for a woman identify
sexual once 15 money hey always cheese
she has major trust issues and a somehow
managed to link fidelity to sexuality
all while wearing a tinfoil hat and
yelling good boxer boy is alive and he
is living in Tucson Arizona he is
keeping it tight you see you would look
a lot better if you leaned against the
bar and then fit your finger like this
meet the director he's the guy who'll
tell you how to act in public if you're
not acting gay enough for him he'll tell
you what to do what to say where to
stand how to stand and keep you going
until you've given an oscar-winning
performance convincing all of his
friends or something that you're not oh
that's great and plus we got it guys
let's go to the Oscars I will drive and
just when you've given up hope you
finally meet the ultimate they get you
no matter what and love you for who you
are
and you realize this has all been
building up to them